we got a little game for you hey okay
since we're celebrating now or never
yep we're gonna play a little now or
never
[Music]
now we're never bring your family on
tour now we're oh now yeah all the time
boys as as often as I can now I'll never
have more kids oh yeah now Cece said me
a text and say hey I'd be like okay okay
nice slow kissing in a fast car jeans
sliding novel away
[Music]
that's got me smile
bars and all the memories remain
now whatever little lion dance at a
country bar line dance
yeah nope there no never not my thing
come on man I could do the Cadillac
Ranch uh-huh that's it but I'm the guy
on the stage and I let everybody dance
oh I'll play the line you are you are
getting them to do the lion dance right
so you know what you're still eating it
right host an awards show
oh absolutely I want to I put that out
in the universe 2020 I'm gonna do it
you told me that you want to do that
almost last year event yeah so you gotta
make
no never Rock a mullet interesting never
like that that's a good question I mean
fashion is cyclical man Never Say Never
yeah you know what I think I'm gonna let
my little baby boy grow one it's gotta
look good under under his little cowboy
yeah but not for me that was that was
the 90s I had an incredible mullet in
1993-94 I'd like to see but if I knew
something I'd like to feel that yeah now
I never record a cover album oh I would
look - hmm now absolutely George Strait
Garth Brooks Eagles Vince Gill okay
anybody CCR you'd be incredible but to
me now I never collaborate with a tour
mate oh yeah absolutely
I got to go tour with Garth Brooks so
let's put that on universe
yeah I'll cover it was like it would be
an organic thing to do
now or never start a line of hats right
boy that's great idea
yeah now let's start on that yeah and
win that how you got to bring me one
okay I have an homage of a problem and
today you know imagine it it would have
looked very Tim McGraw on you with the
turtleneck the great suit and the cowboy
I take it Tim McGraw would have been
very proud
all right so when you put your stamp on
those hats you boom anyone all right oh
I miss you a wolf